well buying a house in today's real
estate market is not
easy first time home buyers are having
an especially difficult time they're
often getting squeezed out of the market
joe moeller is live near saint rose
parkway in the 15 with more on how one
developer though
is looking to help those first-time
buyers hi joe
hey there yeah we shared stories about
buyers moving here to the las vegas area
paying cash for homes and even about
investors looking to make money here
well look at neighborhoods like this
this is called mosaic it's at st rose
parkway and las vegas boulevard
neighborhoods like this
are looking to help first-time home
buyers in this crazy market
i wasn't quite sure that i could really
do it especially on one incomes
nori muhammad recently closed on a
touchstone living home in this north las
vegas neighborhood i was very
surprised considering how many new
construction is going on i didn't
actually think there would be
as many families as there were in a
tough buyer's market she put her name
down
on several waiting lists at new
communities this is the best selling
neighborhood in las vegas
tom mccormick is the president of
touchstone living he says today's market
is not an easy place for first-time home
buyers
people who are renters right now just
don't believe they can ever own a home
and they hear the horrible stories about
bidding and getting outbid
so this neighborhood there's no bidding
buyers coming from out of state are
flocking to las vegas
many from california willing to pay cash
for a new house
mccormick says they don't sell to
investors who are flooding the market
investors are at the very bottom of the
list and we have over 250
people who want to become homeowners
waiting for us to release homes we
simply
it sounds corny but we can't build them
as fast as
people want them there are three
touchstone living neighborhoods around
the valley starting the 200 000
price range touchstone partners with the
bank of nevada to develop land for these
neighborhoods
bill oakley vp of bank of nevada says
this is crucial when the market is like
what it is today
i'm very proud of touchstone for doing
that and focusing on the community
trying to build a community for the
people who work and live here
now back out here live like every other
builder around the valley touchstone
living says a shortage of lumber and
other supplies
is impacting business but they are still
able to close around 30 homes
a month reporting live at st rose
parkway in las vegas boulevard joe
muller 8 news now
such a great idea to serve those
first-time home buyers joe so we asked
with that story in mind on twitter if
you're a first-time homebuyer
and you're out there looking for a home
has it been difficult look at this
78 said yes it is just a tough market
out there
22 percent said nope getting into a home
buyer was fairly easy